number one hamdulillah Isabella near
Hawley police animal bird inaudible
Hondo muhammd autumn alhamdulillah
Camden courier on tiny bunny or Bullock
tighten a high-ranked a deer on Bob an
adulterer ankle in Havana masala to burn
what to slim
Ellen Nabil most powerful Kareem
on our nice little road trip headed to
Key West and we got a nice must [ __ ] out
there we're visiting right what's the
name of it
Malik Malik must sit in Key West I bet
you guys didn't know about that we're
gonna go ahead and bring that to you
soon we're almost there
you try to try to stay what kind of food
you like to eat you started you stay
away from fake food yeah
we do our best to eat organic very
important how important is it I mean to
eat good food it's the key to health
right if you don't need healthy food you
can see the people how they got fight
with this junk food all this yeah
it's poison for this you have to be
healthy take care of yourself coz Allah
let you use this body have take care of
this this is a gift that's right this is
the vehicle that gets us to life
you got honor cherish it develop
nutritional integrity so we're gonna get
some real food over here almonds cashew
look at the beautiful
what a lost month Allah talks about the
tiny box right it's a good look now
we're at the first grade level we're not
talking about the spray the GMOs but
we're just talking about nowadays
because when you go into the center
aisles it's all fake food you got over a
half a million you know that there's
over a half a million fake food items so
we're at the end of the aisle
and we're the best the fruits and
vegetables are look at that this is what
the craters blessed us with look at all
this real food so we're looking for some
some real food there's still dates how's
that let's do that you see the thing
here is you know many people talk about
the sugar that sugars in look you have
natural sugars with the fiber and all
the components because Allah created
heaven that earth put everything in a in
a perfect balance right but you want to
stay away from the processed refined
sugars right anything made in the lab
made in a plant no but if it comes from
a plant from the earth eat it let's do
this what do you think about dates you
like dates
they time beautifully today that's right
I know it's interesting as I saw this
this magazine and you reminded me of the
life that many of our youth and even
adults get drawn into inside the brutal
world of the Mafia but notice what these
two have in common they lived that life
they had all the power money fame women
all the things you can eyes but they're
all gone they left this world so anybody
chasing this type of life this fake life
and wasting their time their efforts the
beautiful gift that God Almighty Allah
has given us it's your chance to turn
away or you end up at the end wasting a
beautiful life with a gift of life and
you end up either in prison like both of
them dead they ended up in prison right
and they just destroyed that chance that
they had so don't don't end up like that
all right
gangster life as Muslims we're not
gangsters when I try to be gangsters you
know we are we are warriors in the path
of the deen striving and struggling to
submit daily to be righteous to be
upright human beings all right